ya he hecho algunos vídeos que cubren lo
que les voy a enseñar en este vídeo las
identidades trigonométricas la razón por
la que estoy haciendo esto es porque yo
mismo necesito repasarlo ya que estaba
resolviendo problemas de cálculo que
requerían que supiera esto además ahora
tengo mejor equipo para grabar así que
dos pájaros de un tiro' grabó de nuevo
un vídeo y al mismo tiempo refresco mi
memoria las identidades trigonométricas
que voy a asumir que ya saben porque he
hecho algunos vídeos sobre ellos son que
el seno de a + b
se nos ve
es igual al seno de a multiplicado por
el coche no debe
más el seno de b
x el coseno de a
esa es la primera que espero que
recordemos y luego si quisiéramos saber
el seno de bueno lo escribir un poco
diferente qué pasaría si quiero saber el
seno de a
más escribir y de esta forma sé que es
lo mismo que decir a menos es cierto
bueno podríamos usar esta fórmula de acá
para decir eso es igual al seno de a x
el coche no de menos
más el seno de menos
x el coche no de a
y sabemos supongo que ese es otro
supuesto que tendremos que mantener en
este vídeo que el cocino de menos es
igual a simplemente el coseno desee
el coche no es una función par y se
podrían dar cuenta de eso al mirar el
gráfico de la función coseno incluso el
círculo trigonométrico mismo y que el
pse no es una función impar que el seno
de menos c es en realidad igual a menos
seno de c
por lo tanto podemos ocupar esa
información para reescribir la segunda
línea de aquí para que diga que el seno
de a menos c
es igual al seno de ha multiplicado por
el coseno dc porque el coste no de menos
es lo mismo que el coste no dc
multiplicado por el coste no de cee y
luego menos el seno de c en vez de
escribir esto podría escribir esto menos
el seno de c
x el coseno de a
así que probamos de cierta manera esto
al saber esto y estoy antemano bastante
bien y voy a usar todas estas para
probar otras identidades trigonométricas
que voy a necesitar bueno la otra
identidad trigonométricas que el jose no
de a más b es igual al coseno de a
en esta situación no se mezclan los
senos con los cosenos el coseno de a x
el seno de b
y esto - oh perdón recién dije que no se
mezclaban y lo terminé haciendo
multiplicado por el coste no debe menos
el seno de a
multiplicado por el seno de p
ahora si quisieran saber cuál es el
coche no de a menos tendrían que usar
las mismas propiedades
el coche no de menos ve que seguirá
siendo coseno de b
así que eso va a hacer el coseno de a x
el coche no coseno de menos b es lo
mismo que el coche no debe pero aquí van
a tener el seno de menos b que es lo
mismo que menos coseno debe eso es menos
se eliminarán por lo que quedaría más
seno de a x el seno de b
así que es un poco confuso cuando tienes
un signo positivo aquí obtienes uno
negativo acá y viceversa pero está
bastante bien no quiero darle mucho
tiempo a eso porque tenemos más
identidades que estudiar
qué pasa si quisiera una identidad para
digamos el coseno de 2
un coseno de 2
bueno son lo mismo que el coseno de
amasar
y podríamos usar esta fórmula de aquí si
mi segunda es simplemente mi b
entonces esto es igual a el coseno de ha
multiplicado por el coseno de a menos el
seno de a
multiplicado por el seno de a me ves
también una en esta situación por lo que
podría reescribir lo como esto es igual
al coseno al cuadrado de a
ahí escribí coseno de la x coseno de por
sí mismo - el seno al cuadrado de a
esto ya es una identidad del coche
novedosa es igual al coseno al cuadrado
de a menos el seno al cuadrado de a voy
a resaltar las identidades que
ocuparemos en este vídeo
entonces ya les mostré esa que pasa si
no estoy satisfecho qué pasa si solo lo
quiero en términos de cosenos bueno
podríamos derivar la definición del
círculo trigonométrico de nuestras
funciones trigonométricas está la
identidad más fundamental el seno al
cuadrado de ar
más el coche no al cuadrado de es igual
a 1 o podríamos escribir déjeme pensar
en la mejor manera de hacer esto
podríamos escribir que el seno al
cuadrado de a es igual a 1 - el cocer al
cuadrado de a
y luego podríamos tomar este sustituirlo
por esto así podríamos reescribir esta
identidad y decir que es igual al coseno
al cuadrado de a menos el seno al
cuadrado de a pero el seno al cuadrado
de a es esto de aquí así que lo haré en
otro color
- 1 - el coseno al cuadrado de a eso es
lo que sustituir por el seno al cuadrado
de a y esto es igual al coseno al
cuadrado de a menos uno más el coce no
al cuadrado de a es igual a sólo estamos
sumando esto voy a continuar al lado
derecho
tenemos un consejo al cuadrado de amor
otro coseno al cuadrado de así que es 2
coseno al cuadrado de a menos 1
y todo eso es igual al coseno de 2 ahora
qué pasa si quisiera obtener una
identidad que me dijera cuál es el
coseno al cuadrado de a en estos
términos podemos hacer eso
si sumamos uno ambos lados de la
ecuación de hecho voy a escribir esto
esta es una de nuestras identidades pero
si sumamos uno a ambos lados de la
ecuación conseguimos dos multiplicado
por el coseno al cuadrado de a es igual
al coseno de 2 a 1
y si dividimos ambos lados por 2
obtenemos que el coseno al cuadrado de a
es igual a un medio
podemos reordenar esto para hacerlo
x uno más el coseno de 2a
y eso es todo ya tenemos otra identidad
jose no al cuadrado de aa veces llamada
identidad reducida
y qué pasa si quisiéramos algo en
términos del seno al cuadrado de a
bueno tendríamos que revisar estoy
arriba y sabríamos a partir de estas
identidades que el seno al cuadrado de a
es igual a uno menos el coste no al
cuadrado de a o podríamos hacer el otro
modo podríamos restar seno al cuadrado
de a ambos lados obtendríamos lo
explicaré acá abajo si restar a seno al
cuadrado de a de ambos lados
obtendríamos cociendo al cuadrado de a
es igual al seno al cuadrado de a
y luego podríamos volver a esta fórmula
de carrió y podríamos escribir esto lo
haré en celeste
podríamos escribir que el coche no de 2a
es igual a
en vez de escribir cosas al cuadrado de
a escribir esto es igual a 1 - seno al
cuadrado de a menos el seno al cuadrado
de a por lo que mi coseno de 2a es igual
a
es igual a veamos tengo el menos seno al
cuadrado de a menos otros en al cuadrado
de así que tengo uno menos dos seno al
cuadrado de a ahora tengo otra identidad
otra forma de escribir mi coche no de
dos estamos descubriendo muchas formas
de escribir con seno de dos a ahora sí
quisiéramos resolver el seno al cuadrado
de dos a podríamos sumarlo ambos lados
de la ecuación
haré eso y lo escribiría acá para
ahorrar espacio bajar un poco la
pantalla
lo haré aquí entonces si sumó 12 no al
cuadrado de a ambos lados de esto
consigo dos seno al cuadrado de a
más el coseno de 2 es igual a 1
resto coseno de 2a de ambos lados y
consigo dos seno al cuadrado de a es
igual a uno menos el coste no de 2a
luego divido ambos lados de esto por dos
y consigo seno al cuadrado de a es igual
a un medio x 1 - coseno de 2a
tenemos otro descubrimiento creo que
podría llamarse otro hallazgo y es
interesante siempre es interesante ver
la simetría coseno al cuadrado son
idénticos salvo por el más dos a en el
caso del coche no al cuadrado y el menos
coseno de dos en el caso de sean o al
cuadrado así que ya encontramos un
montón de cosas interesantes veamos si
podemos hacer algo con el coseno o con
el seno perdón de 2a voy a elegir un
color que no haya ocupado
bueno prácticamente hemos ocupado todos
los colores ya entonces si queremos
encontrar el seno de 2a
eso es igual al seno de a más
seno de a más
que es igual al seno de a x el que en
realidad no lo quiero hacer tan enredado
x el coseno de a más
y este coseno de a es la segunda podría
verse de ese modo más el seno
simplemente estoy ocupando el seno de
ambas b más el seno de la segunda
multiplicado por el coste no de la
primera acabo de escribir la misma cosa
dos veces así que estoy simplemente
igualados seno de a jose no de a eso fue
un poco más fácil así que el seno de 2a
es igual a eso
y eso es otro resultado yo estoy un poco
cansado de jugar con todos estos senos y
cosenos y puede obtener todos los
resultados que quería para mis problemas
de cálculo así que espero que haya sido
un buen repaso para ustedes porque sí
que lo fue para mí pueden anotar estas
cosas memorizar las si así lo quieren
pero lo que realmente importa de todo
esto darse cuenta de que pueden derivar
todas estas fórmulas a partir de las
fórmulas iniciales con las que partimos
el vídeo e incluso tengo pruebas para
mostrarles cómo derivar las a partir de
las definiciones básicas de sus
funciones trigonométricas